hey what's up my name is samuel leeds i
am with alastair
and russell and we're going to be
talking today about hmos it's going to
be a short
sharp video about hmos this is not going
to be anything like
the property investors podcast which by
the way is awful
awful you're welcome well it's long and
you just chit chat
and talk about how your week has been
no one cares about that on my channel
you guys just want content content
content right
if you do comment below oh here comes a
story it's not a story i'm just saying
maybe but i mean our podcast to be fair
did get a lot more views than your
podcast so much so that you had to close
your podcast
is that what happened yeah i don't even
know probably didn't that what happened
pav
i think papa's gonna back me up every
time it's more of a as it's a more of a
podcast feel so yeah we chitchat about
what we've done
and property well here you are in the
studio with me
uh hmos we i was in burnley the other
day and
and the who's the hmon manager from
burnley the lady
what what janice was saying that she's
got 200 rooms
196 of them are full yeah and it's crazy
because
eight months ago people were saying to
me hmos is going to be a thing of the
past
no one's going to be able to afford hmos
people will say that but you weren't
saying that i wasn't saying that
you saw what i was saying what was i
saying what was i saying a year ago or
six six months ago you predicted hmos
will boom
i did and you guys agreed
what is so funny you you guys we sort of
predicted it eight months ago
we predicted it six and a half months
ago
here's what happens guys i make property
predictions in fact their whole podcast
was created to discuss this youtube
channel that was the purpose of their
little little
little podcast but now i make
predictions and then they try and take
credit for the predictions but we can
all win together we can all but here's
the thing i think we all agreed we all
agreed we did
we did we all agreed after you've been
educated by my youtube videos we all
agreed but here's the thing
um right now is it a good time to get to
hmos
how do you get into hmos um what about
the eviction
bans all that stuff i want to give
practical step-by-step advice in terms
of hmo so alistair what are you thinking
what's happening do you know something
um with the covert 19 that has been a
boom for hmos i'll tell you why because
people cannot
afford necessarily to have individual
homes so what they're doing is they're
moving into hmos they're taking on the
rooms but has to be ensuite
um what we're finding with uh certainly
our investors and what i'm doing
um is that the rooms are filling up more
quicker if they're on suite but that
didn't used to be the case did it
i mean i wrote i wrote a book back in
2016 actually had a
chapter headed on sweets are poo meaning
they're a rubbish investment and whilst
i think that's still true in some areas
in some markets generally speaking you
are correct people are wanting ensuite
rooms
the standard of living is going up
because people are getting richer
because they're joining our discovery
days
yeah of course of course absolutely the
thing is you know um
it's also the speed of how quickly they
rent out if it's on-suite it's more
appealable it rents out much much
quicker more appealable i don't know
that was a word but i've just made it up
i've kind of just made that word up
but you know you heard it here for you
yes the essence is true though so okay
so ensuites
rent to hmo yeah risk area
where do you find them yeah the problem
is that's your bag you've got so many of
these the problem with rent
hmo if you're going to go for your own
suite area is what are you going to do
you're going to put on suites into a
into a rental property you're not going
to do that
no you're not so they have to be there
um they have to already use
new houses so like my house your house i
mean how many bathrooms did your house
have
oh dude four or five i think it's more
maybe more i don't know i've not been in
them but but
i think it's six but my point is you've
got six bathrooms six bedrooms
yeah so like no come on man not all
houses are that size
not all houses are like what we're stood
in at there but russell's point is
people want a bathroom they don't want
to share it
but most new builds though if you are
from what i've seen anyway no they are
they're building now bathroom
per bedroom if it's a four bed house
it's gonna have four toilets in it and
and i had an argument
argument about a conversation with kevin
macleod from grand designs about this
and he was saying how he thinks it's
stupid
they shouldn't what about the old days
when they queued for a bathroom and i
was like but kevin
that sucked who wants to queue for a
bathroom well like the old days where
they had a
bathroom at the bottom of the garden
what about the old days when they didn't
have mobile phones and when they went on
horseback carriages let's just go back
to that but they did used to have the
battery in the bottom of the garden
didn't they yeah
then they brought the bathroom to the
house then it was downstairs so here's
my advice in terms of rent to hmos i
would suggest if you want to
rent to hmo go on spare room find
people that are managing it themselves
hopefully find ones that are a little
bit shabby where some of the rooms are
empty
contact them and say hey how many rooms
you got available this is exactly what
happened
um about two weeks ago on a discovery
day we had a client there exact same
thing looking for rent to rent hmo
so we showed them how to jump onto the
registers and find these hmos yeah
and i know they're out getting looking
at leads and they're out actually
looking at these deals so
they're they're everywhere because
everywhere there's hmos as tired
landlords and if you can offer them a
solution to get
them out of it and you in great and this
is what russell does because
russell's so crafty
because what russell does sneaky we call
it sneaky yeah sneaky
manipulative no we just russell's a
great businessman but what russell
russell does is when he's speaking to
people he'll get the calculator out
there and then so he'll be having a
conversation with a landlord if he's
trying to
negotiate you've managed hundreds of hmo
rooms you know doing a lot of different
contracts rent to rent and management
but what russell will do is he'll say to
the landlord how many rooms are empty
there but oh three rooms remember
there's five rooms so you've got two
rooms full at the moment yeah
so how much income are you making right
now 800 pounds but minus your bills and
stuff let's work it out to get
calculated what are you left with right
now
and then it's like they'll be left like
300 quid a month well how about i'll
give you 300 quid a month ago
but i'm not a minute but there's three
rooms empty exactly they're empty
so you've got peace of mind i'll give
you 300 pounds a month yeah
but you know what let's call it 400.
i'll pay you that guaranteed for three
years have a theme of break clause
get the calculate work it out sign try
and get the deal done
and then you're then of course going to
manage it properly or get someone to
manage it properly what's all this i
heard about you through the grapevine
with your new big hmo that you're going
to be managing it yourself
right okay it's a test it's a it's an
experiment that's it that's it
is aren't you past the stage of testing
whether you should manage it yourself no
no no do you know what it is no i'm
interested in hearing it do you know
what it is
okay i've got multiple multiple hmos and
it's
a sustainable matter every single month
i get a statement and i'm like what's
that for what's that for what's up or
what's that for
and it just takes off the bottom line
you know i would do that in that case
manage it all yourself
get rid of all your staff just do
everything yourself in fact why get
passive income when you can have active
income
so what i mean this one i'm doing i'm
i'm doing completed i know you might
he can really do that you know what's in
bedford did i tell you yeah i know it's
bedford
do you know how like the the tenants are
causing problems yeah right what are you
living at yourself
why don't you evict all of the tenants
have no problems you could you could
live in it yourself
you could manage it yourself you could
do everything yourself alistair
basically what you're saying is you
your your hm management companies aren't
operating that well no
they are they're they're doing a good
job but i just i just wanted for three
months that's what i'm gonna do for
three months i'm gonna i'm gonna put the
tenants in myself i'm gonna manage
myself and see how much it's gonna do we
do this to be fair
we sometimes if it's for three months we
sometimes say we're gonna do
our staff's job usually for three days
but fair enough
um we're gonna do our staff's job for a
few days and then what we do is we find
out how we we could
to be fair because we're kind of awesome
probably do it better than
most of our staff so no offense
power to be fair depends on the job
videography no yeah yeah
right but you know what that will
sometimes say right let's jump on the
customer i'll sometimes jump on the
customer service course
especially if i'm getting if on the
feedback forms people as i said oh no
i'm responding to my email the person on
the phone will sloppy i'm like let me
and russell
and some of the directors come and do
the job for three days
and then we'll outperform our staff and
then we'll go what will we do different
then we'll train them
based because you can't be delegating
jobs if you don't do it yourself that's
why i believe you should manage
properties yourself to begin with
then get management companies what
you're saying is you want to go back to
managing yourself just to figure out how
to do better to then train them better
just because i want to maximize the
income from it
and i want to stop all these additional
costs that are just popping up left
right and center
like um miscellaneous costs and i
i always have they're just miscellaneous
they're just miscellaneous and i have to
i have to ring them up and go what the
[ __ ] are miscellaneous though
well it could be things like they've got
two it could be
what were they i can't remember because
i couldn't even bother ringing them up
well can't you just tell you can't
bother to ring them up to ask them but
you can be able to manage it yourself
yes for three months because how's that
i've got a miscellaneous cost
i would personally do it for three
months that's it ask for a breakdown
that's it give me a breakdown anyway um
okay so
hmos good time booming why are hmos
booming on the stairs right now despite
what everybody said six months ago
i was right you guys were right as well
why why are they booming a couple of
reasons
one um people want people okay
money it basically comes down to money
okay a lot of people are having their
cash flow
uh restricted so they're looking to
relocate and they're
looking to find more affordable living
hmos provide that solution
one price every single month all your
bills included
nice easy location good condition
generally and it's it's easy it's
flexible they don't have to be there for
five years they can be there for six
months
do you think do you think that might be
why do you think it might be because
they're going more
mass market why on suites are more
important because the majority of people
you know what unless they're saying
which is so important as they're saying
that hmos are a really good product yeah
they're a good product people want them
people are queuing up for them you can
say
put in any area of spare room there'll
be rooms one at all time but what
russell's saying is there's more supply
so the key is do hmos you're going to
fill them but make sure your supply is
good
it's your product isn't it as you said
it's your product so you wouldn't have a
company
that has a [ __ ] product you'd have a
company that has an amazing product
it's this thing that's what you want you
want the best possible product you can
house is your product
and if you say i'm allergic to tenants
you're a dummy because your tenants are
your customer
and you better love your customer
because they're the one that gives you
the money to become financially
independent
you're in the financial independent
you're financially independent i'm
financially independent
get around people that are financially
independent because if you don't
you're not either if you've got five bum
friends guess what you're going to be
you're going to be the sixth bum
so my advice would be get around people
environment is stronger than world power
we talk about that on the discovery days
what is it russell mentioned just in a
couple words this is the sales pitch now
i'm just kind of kidding or am i
what's your discovery day so discovery
day is where a small group of people
come down to our
office meet samuel myself understand
whoever's around
and samuel work with you to put together
a step-by-step
plan of how you're going to become
successful in properties this is
literally just like
five or ten people max especially
because of covid
round the table we chat we talk we
brainstorm we talk about all our further
training as well we'll talk about the
academy
any money that you pay for the discovery
day you can use that as a voucher to go
on any other training so it's almost
like it's kind of free it is free for
anyone that becomes a student yeah so if
you're interested in the discovery days
if you want to come and meet me
you want to meet russell maybe even of
stairs you sometimes show your face
he gets involved in the training this
guy's a good trainer very good trainer
uh come on down i'll leave a link in the
description for the discovery day and
it's their final words why should they
book on the discovery day right now
let me tell you why because do you know
what i was at one of these discovery
days
uh two weeks ago uh there was from a
couple that flew over
uh they just moved over from australia
and the first thing they done in
property was come to the discovery day
and they're actually making proper
property moves right now
because of what they're learning from
the discovery day training that we're
giving them and you know what
you you can't miss it because how
look i know there's an investment right
but then you're going to have all these
people educating your training
i don't know 500 quid or something and
as you said
like mind-blowing stuff i'm talking
about your own stuff but also fast
results
you can get fast results i'm not talking
get rich quick but i'm talking get
results quick
and get wealthy and rich over a period
of time so book on the discovery day
below
if you liked this video please do us a
massive favor and smash the like button
also subscribe if you want to see more
of russell anderstev running their
podcast
you can listen to them on itunes you can
list them on spotify or if you want to
watch them on youtube as well you can
check out the podcast right here
boom just above russell's face if you
want to subscribe to my channel you
should definitely do that you can do
that right here just above alastair's
face
and uh i'm going to keep my face playing
all right i'll see you guys real soon
peace out